people throughout my career I've asked
me Pat what can I do for you to mentor
me directly many times people ask Pat I
want you to mentor me directly I have a
very simple criteria if a person I don't
care if you're extremely talented you
have a degree you don't have a degree
nationality I don't care any if you
don't have a strong work ethic I can't
work with you here's why because
whatever I transfer to you you are not
going to give the highest return
possible for whatever knowledge and
skill set that's been passed over to you
why am I going to put the time into you
if the duplication part is not going to
return why am I saying this to you
you're not working with me you're from
192 different countries if you want to
get somebody to work with you directly
that they know what they're doing or if
you want to get right partners you've
got to have a strong work ethic so what
prompted this episode here is we got at
least 200 messages emails snapchats
Facebook people saying Pat you keep
talking about work ethic can you please
explain how one can improve their work
ethic and I said I'm going to take it a
step even past that so today's video is
not for the people that subscribe to the
4-hour workweek by Tim Ferriss this is
not the video for you this is not the
video for people that want to be online
consultants who want to not have any
real place of business and have people
that are virtual assistants that do
their own part and you are not working
that much and you're at home and you
work three hours a day this is not the
video for you because those names
although you can do that there's a big
movement of 4-hour workweek today no
4-hour work week develops an apple no
4-hour work week develops a business
that ends up becoming a substantial
business doing one hundred two hundred
three hundred million dollars per day
don't now if one of to do it that's an
anomaly I'm not talking about the one or
two I'm talking majority I'm talking to
the people who have plans of running a
big business touching people touching
clients growing their businesses that's
why I'm talking to in this video so
that's the message here how to improve
your work ethic as an entrepreneur now
let's dissect the word work ethic I'm
going to do this in a way where you'll
see what the meaning
work ethic is then you need to make the
decision of what that means to you so
simple the definition of work what is
the definition of work here's the
definition of work activity involving
mental or physical effort done in order
to achieve a purpose or result again
activity involving mental or physical
effort done in order to achieve a
purpose or result that's the definition
of work now what's the definition of
ethic in Greek the definition of ethic
is the science of morals the science of
morals ethic work ethic the science of
morals what does it mean the science of
morals I don't even understand the
definition somebody may say well then
why don't we break down what morals
means
so here's morals the definition of
morals is if we really dissect the word
work ethic morals means a person's
standard your standards of behavior or
beliefs concerning what is and is not
acceptable to you simple let me say one
more time
morals means a personal standard of
behavior your standard of behavior or
your belief what you believe is right or
wrong
a person standards of behavior or
beliefs concerning what is right and
what is not acceptable to you what is
and what is not acceptable to you so
let's go through one more time work
activity that requires effort to achieve
a purpose
ethics science of morals morals standard
of behavior that is or is not acceptable
to you so work ethic when people say how
do i improve my work ethic I don't know
your standard I don't know your belief
system I don't know what you're staying
for I don't know your vision I don't
know your mission I don't know what you
want to be I don't know who you want to
be I don't know how big you want to
build I don't want to how big of a
legacy you want to leave I don't know
who you want to be do you want to be a
4-hour workweek and you make money
saying I don't work
I don't have an office and I don't have
this and I don't have that and you want
to be a minimalist that's great that's
your prerogative but I don't know your
vision I don't know your standards there
are a lot of people today in America
that want to make money without doing a
lot of work and that is respected today
that is respected today people respect
people who make money not working people
respect that that's okay that is morally
okay to you I have a different level of
morally okay to me when it comes out to
work ethic for me it's completely
different I grew up watching my father
work from five o'clock in the morning
till 9:00 at night two hours away we
live in Tehran Iran and the city he
worked there was a city called chat ad
and it was two and a half hours away and
he drove a car car that was called Jian
Jian is like a Pinto of Iran and France
Jian mida would go back and forth he
would work six days a week cuz in Iran
to get one day off and it was Friday
Iran's America Sunday in Iran is Friday
he would come on Friday and he was with
us all day Friday we'd wake up in the
morning go to particle Shahen shahi then
we'd come back go to church then we go
to my grandma's house then we'd come
home he would take a two-hour nap on his
famous couch then couch is done with he
wakes up we playing wrestle we have
dinner we watch a movie at 8:30 we go to
bed that's my father's standards that he
said for me when I watch stories of Sam
Walton which is a CEO and entrepreneur
that I want to mimic or a person whose
standard is a job or somebody here that
worked very hard who is constantly in
creation well that's my standard I don't
know your standard for you maybe Tim
Ferriss for you maybe somebody else for
you maybe somebody that makes money
while they're not creating only maybe
they're creating content and telling
people how to find and make a lot of
money traveling the world and making
money I'm not this in it it's not mine
so I'm not here how to live your life
I'm not here to tell you how to live
your life I'm not here how to for you to
change your work ethic and all that
stuff but you need to take inventory of
yourself today finding out what your
purpose of your life is what do you want
to achieve what type of effort do you
want to put in what activity do you need
to create what are your science of
morals and what standards of behavior do
you want to have that is and it's not
acceptable to you that's what you need
to figure out anything else I say to in
this video is irrelevant anything else
anything else I tell you in this video
is purely irrelevant anything else I
tell you is irrelevant it doesn't matter
because somebody's going to say oh you
know what I don't agree with this old
type of working and overworking yourself
and etc etc that's your standard that's
your moral of a science or morals
that's yours okay oh I think this is
just ridiculous you know this is why
people in America and capitals and makes
you overworked in Papa Papa Papa I'm
sorry you're watching the video on
YouTube which is created by capitalist
so what do you want to say don't watch
the video is created by capitalists turn
that phone off and throw it on track
it's invented by capitalists turn your
computer off
it's invented by capitalists take your
clothes up and trash them it's invented
by capitalists stop watching TV
it's invented by capitalists turn the
complete books off and burn the books
and throw them away it's produced by a
capitalist take that candle off and stop
reading the books that kendall is
produced by capitalists okay so you
decide this now since I have made this
clear now let me explain to you how you
can improve your work ethic and how I
improved my work ethic over the years as
a brand-spanking-new salesperson then as
a brand-spanking-new supervisor manager
then entrepreneur then you know CEO then
founder then board member then value
then all this other stuff I'm going to
just tell you what some tips that work
with me over theirs and hopefully it'll
do the same for you here's first things
first to me somebody with a strong work
ethic is predictable every day every day
what is predictable you show up at 8:00
you leave at midnight you show up at
8:00 you leave at 8:00 you show up at
7:00 you leave at 9:00 you show up at
7:00 you leave at 10:00 I don't know but
it's predictable and you do it every day
it doesn't matter what it is there's a
predictable work effort being put by you
let me explain something to you a lot of
people will come and say pac-man you
know one day I want to be a millionaire
but you know what I got you know for me
it didn't kind of work out I did a
conference call today's Friday yesterday
and this conference call
with a group of 40 entrepreneurs
builders that are doing a very very good
job in our firm and I put them on the
column one of the one of the guys on the
conference call
ask me a question ask somebody a
question about momentum and what can I
do to do this and this and this and that
I said listen those who steadily grow
their business show up every single day
without any disruptions because every
time you disrupt and you have a crisis
to you it's a crisis to somebody else it
may be a crisis but they don't handle it
as big of a weight as you do
your momentum goes all the way back down
to level number one again and you have
to recreate momentum it's a pain in the
butt okay if you truly want to have
steady growth in your business you've
got to be predictable because the moment
you stop you lose all your momentum so
if you really really want to expand your
business the purpose of you growing is a
big purpose that you have whatever that
purpose is you've got to be predictable
and throughout the time you're
predictable you got to accept and
anticipate crisis is going to happen
what's crisis a breakup with a
girlfriend cannot throw you off for two
months because then you're not
predictable kid gets in trouble in
school cannot throw you off for three
weeks because then you're not
predictable you and your wife get into a
terrible fight cannot throw you off
because then you're not predictable you
have a certain financial challenge
cannot throw you off because you're now
not predictable
you have somebody in your family that
talked smack about you cannot stop
because you're no longer predictable by
the way the person that makes it also
had all those crises happen but they
stay predictable part of big work ethic
is predictability number two consistency
same thing you show up but consistency
and you keep showing up and you keep
doing your work predictability at the
same time I keep coming consistency is I
keep showing up to big difference sounds
the same but slightly different 8:00
a.m. I come in but I'm consistent with
what I'm doing with my efforts because
I'm consistently compounding my efforts
because eventually after enough
consistent effort all of a sudden I'm
going to have an inevitable explosion in
my business that takes place okay number
three prepared a knife before proper
preparation prevents poor performance
and old mentor mine told me this proper
and this was a man that he would always
brag about the fact that he's not
talented he was never the best speaker I
like them because every
I spoke to him it was discipline strong
he lived in a beautiful 18,000 square
foot house with planes and married I
think he had six seven eight kids always
stable always solid but every time I
talked to him he had written read
thinking Grow Rich to 300 times think
about this guy and everything to was
about preparation
he said Pat the guy that's the most
prepared wins everything was about
preparation every time he talked he had
a three by five card with them every
time three by five card with them three
by five card with them three by five
card with them
preparation prepared a night before
prepare Sunday before prepared a week
before prepare before the meeting
prepared before the conference prepared
before you preparing everything is about
preparation if I'm supposed to give a
speech nine months from now I already
have a folder made and my phone and I
just keep adding stuff that I'm going to
talk about in that meeting that's nine
months from now nine months of
preparation of adding notes and the
phone to prepare for something like that
that's part of work ethic that is work
ethic number four do more let me know
what I mean by do more I remember I was
in an office how was brand spanking new
its 2002 2003 and I'm in an office of
victory and Balboa in the city of Encino
California and Saturdays we were all
young and there was a bunch of pretty
girls in the office and everybody
Saturday night wanted to go to Dublin's
Dublin's was a place to be right
everybody wanted to go to Dublin's you
wanted to go to saddle ranch and
Miyagi's it was all in the same corner
like literally 300 yards away you go
Dublin's across the street Miyagi's and
you go to satirize boom boom boom boom
boom boom if you want to go to after
hours you could everybody wanted to go
clubbing Saturday night and I was in the
office five o'clock everyone's leaving
six two people left seven I'm staying
no one's there eight I'm staying nine
I'm staying 10 I'm stayin everyone's
gone eleven I'm stayin by that time I'm
so wiped out I'm not goin to the club
I'm goin home reading a book honestly
boring - you're right it's boring to you
right now fast forward and asked me what
places are partied and have had fun with
you won't even believe half the stores
if I told you you would think I'm
telling you story out of a movie you
would say there's no way in the world
you've party with prime ministers and
and princes and governors and Senators
and Bill
and all this other stuff because I
didn't want to just get too excited
about Dublin's there was a time was
exciting to me there was a time Yogi's
was exciting to me there was a time all
that stuff was exciting to me again how
big is your purpose how big is your
purpose how long will you put your
activity with the effort and then
there's a match to standard of behavior
that you want to put up so do more if a
person leaves at 6 you leave at 8 if a
person makes 100 calls today you make
200 calls a day if a person makes 50
contacts that you make 75 if a person
writes you know sells 20 of your product
you sell 40 okay if somebody practices
three hours you practice five hours if
somebody practices six hours you
practice eight hours if someone reads
two books you read four books just do a
little bit more do a little bit more do
a little bit more number five subscribe
to the now mentality subscribe to the
now mentality
we'll call him tomorrow uh-huh we'll
call him now so the other day one of my
guys his name is Fred he calls me he
says hey man I'm kind of disappointed
you know because the office leased that
I wanted didn't go through and this is a
commercial real estate agent that he's
flopped with me three times and I made
this guy $200,000 three times he's let
down referrals that I gave this guy
don't do well with people who I give
referrals to I expect perfection from
somebody I give a referral to right so
I'm gonna make you money that's a market
I'm introducing you my credibility is on
the line this guy did it three times I
said what did he do he says well you
know we're just not getting the deal I
text them right there while I'm on the
phone with speakwrite takes a commercial
real estate agent he doesn't respond I
call his office he doesn't respond I
call his phone he doesn't respond I
asked to talk to a supervisor I talked
to a supervisor I said who's the owner
of the company they put me on the phone
with the owner of the company I talked
to the president the company the
president company got a call from me
within one hour I got a call back from
everybody I got a text back from
everybody I've got the guy Fred ended up
getting exactly what he wanted from the
office all the expectation they lowered
it from a five-year lease to three
release why because it's do it now do
you know what was a crazy stink fred
told me press it oh my gosh I'm a little
bit nervous I'm like why are you nervous
it because I can't believe you just did
all that stuff in ten minutes I said
it's called a do it now mentality
well what are we going to wait till
tomorrow hey Pat there's just somebody
that may be interested let's call him
Ryan you got a small number it's column
with you right yeah come right now what
are you talking about now
do it now mentality work ethic is a part
of it now do it now not so more now now
now let's do right now okay
procrastinate tomorrow next day three
hours five hours let's do it right now
next point number six find running mates
I love people that work as hard as men
they push me there's nothing like it I
love running mates I love people I say
Pat five more reps
let's do it I'm tired Pat five more reps
because some days you don't feel like it
Pat come on Pat five more outside come
on come on bro my shoulders I given up
coffee have four more three more pack
come on come on ten more calls come on
guys ten more calls running mates
running mate so push each other running
mate so push each other
there's nothing like finding a good
running mate that pushes you working
hard buddies if you want to call it that
and eventually it's unfortunately
sometimes you end up not finding anybody
else that wants to work at your pace and
then you're working buddies may not be
in the same place your ad they may be
complete different place and you play
games with each other hey what time you
wake can i play what time you're doing
this that's your working buddies next
number seven don't fall for the work
smart only concept for our work week is
work smart I get it
I respect it some people like that
standard of behavior your morale your
standard it's fine
nothing big has ever been built without
working very hard and I'm talking very
hard very hard
it's Friday night right now what we're
shooting this everybody's gun in the
office dennis is here former eight year
DBT Dallas Police Department I'm here
we're shooting this I am willing to bet
everyone's out of the office except for
Mario and probably Paul is sitting
somewhere here's what's right or not
it's already seven o'clock everyone's
going out to dinner all day I just got
back from Burbank California I was in
Bakersfield California was in Houston
Texas I got a bunch of other travels
that's coming up we're here right now in
the office why are we doing this for Pat
how do you find the time to shoot these
episodes you never miss a Tuesday in the
Thursday episode of value tainment
because some nights on Friday night I
want to go home and kick it and relax
and I don't and we shoot these episode
because we're supposed to come to you
Tuesdays and Thursdays and do you
realize
from the moment we said Tuesdays and
Thursdays we've never ever done an
episode that we've missed on Tuesday or
Thursday why it's part of commitment
it's part of being predictable it's part
of showing up and there are days right
now my back I'm not gonna lie to you we
did legs with my personal trainer Josh
my hamstrings are so tight right now
Mario was stretching me right now I
can't even I can't even go like that
right now come on I can breathe I can't
breathe
when I'm going that it's that bad not
because of my lower back pain my
hamstrings it doesn't matter so when
people tell me but I'm sick I have this
up that and this is not your game yet
then this is not your game yet
okay next eight cut distractions cut
distractions very simple you got to cut
distractions you're still going to have
some distractions in your life but you
got to cut the distractions that you can
cut get rid of the distractions get rid
of the you know in the office you know
there's a lot of different stuff that
can take time away from you I don't want
it I want to cut distractions I want to
cut any kind of distractions I can cut
in my life I don't want to deal with
office politics I want to perform
so there's office politics you go
perform you don't need to deal with it
you go grow your business number nine
absolute focus absolute focus this is
tiring
believe me I'm not the I'm the ADHD guy
and you know how ADHD is they don't know
how to focus I'm the guy that would see
something I'm gone boom I'm looking at
all this other stuff you got to train
your mind to be focused it's a muscle
you got to train your mind to be focused
you can do some when people tell me all
these rhetoric I need to take adding I
need to take this medicine I need to
take that medicine stop you're looking
for an out you may need to take that
medicine I'm not questioning your doctor
all I'm telling you is stop making
excuses that you can't stay focused
practice it it's a muscle stay focused
next have a to do list work ethic has to
do with to-do list what needs to get
done next when you get done next right
now Mario and I about four hours ago I
told Mr Mario Mario wanted to add
another project who are lists of
projects that let me show you what we
got I just that's all I did too let me
show to you I went through every single
things as pad I got the point so you
want to add another thing here's what we
got what else you want to do what else
you want to do can you handle this no
we're not ready it
let's wait 90 more days
stay with 90 more days okay next eat
right work ethic requires energy for you
to be able to last a long time stamina
efficiency for you to be able to go and
you you have the you know you're not
getting tired by four o'clock if you eat
right you're going to be able to stick
around even longer number 12 plug the
leaks
I don't like leaks when I worked at
Bally's I told a story about Bally's
early but when I worked at Bally's I
wanted to find out where the leaks were
it doesn't matter what the leaks were
the leaks were some of the tours were
taking way too long so the person coming
back here was given a 40-hour tour of
the gym you could do that in 13 minutes
why are you doing a 40-hour tour just
because she's pretty
we just lost 37 minute 27 minutes of
your time I need you to be back you're
making calls this is why we're not
hitting our goal so plug the leaks
what's the leak the leak is you know
when I make the call I'm doing this then
I'm doing this and I'm doing this that
took seven seconds
plug the leaks it's a waste of my time
what's the leak another leak is I'm
going from here to here I'm going to
find a fastest way to get home or I'm
going to plug whatever leaks you got
with your business there's a lot of
leaks work ethic requires you to plug
the leaks and figure out exactly what
those leaks are they waste way too much
time next cut the fat similar to cut the
distractions but cut the fat there's a
lot of fat it's work you don't need to
do it's work that somebody else can do
it's work that makes you feel excited
that you got stuff done not necessarily
didn't grow your business you just want
to go home send your work hard we didn't
get nothing done there are days that you
work and you go home and say what
happened today to my business how did
the value my business increase today it
didn't but I feel like I work ten hours
this one guy told me I'm at the office
every damn day Patrick he's screaming in
my face you're telling me I don't work
that hard
how the hell can you be at the office 60
hours a week and in a month you only
sell four of them you tell me how tell
me I said your wife is sitting right
here you're telling you working hard
what do mean you working hard you ain't
working hard just because you're at the
office doesn't mean you're working hard
Mans to cut the fat turn off the
Facebook turn off snapchat may just
fight make some calls contact reach out
to somebody you're not focused you need
to cut the fat and then he did then his
business blew up
next drop perfection let me tell you
what I mean by drop perfection sometimes
a person doesn't work as hard because
they're trying to do it so perfectly
that they don't even take the shot if
you don't take the shot the we run out
of time you lose the game anyways guess
what if there's six seconds left on the
shot clock and you look for the perfect
shot what's the chances of you winning
if you don't get the perfect shot you
just you're not going to because you got
to take the shot so guess what no matter
what you got to take the shot
what is take the shot go to that
appointment go to the it's contradiction
of preparation I get it but I would much
rather have you take the shot then not
take the shot
work a lot on being prepared but don't
don't expect to have a perfect
environment all the time seek magic more
than you're seeking perfection in your
business
perfection prevents explosion many many
times
times because it's never going to be
perfect so people wait for a perfect
time to hit it you just got to hit it
okay and then how to avoid burnout which
is something people ask me about burnout
Pat how do I avoid burnout have you one
escape
here's what I mean by escape I went to
the movies every single month middle the
day at 10 o'clock and I went to watch a
movie by myself with 80 year old folks
so watch out 10 o'clock it was my escape
was my therapy
it was my escape I would work so hard
every other week I was at the spa
getting a massage every other week I get
a massage at the spa every other week I
get a massage at the spa Sundays when I
was single every Sunday I went to the
beach every single Sunday I'd go to the
beach wake up in the morning go do the
stairs in Santa Monica I would go do the
dunes the sand dunes and then I would go
to the beach I'd go sit down and read
I'd come back I'd see that PF Changs my
favorite waiter well I'd go to Earth
cafe and I'd sit and order the same
exact way that Earth Cafe which we no
longer have in Dallas Texas Dallas has
got to get some earth cafe because it's
insane I'm missing my earth cafe and
then out come on but I had my rituals
you got to find ways to have your own
release you got to find ways to have
your own escape you got to find ways to
have that as well and then I always
selfishly rewarded myself it didn't
matter what it was if you do this fact
we're getting this if we do this we're
buying a Harley if we do this we're
buying an S 600 if we do this we're
going to go shopping $5,000 if we do
this you go into this place if we do
this you go into this if you do this you
go into New York New Year's Eve if you
do this you're going to qualify for this
trip if you do there's always got to be
that part because if there isn't then
you got to have the carrot there's no
motivation you need a carrot but you got
to create the carrot yourself to have a
stronger war kit because if you don't
you'll hit 100 grand you stop you're the
core demony you stop you're the
milestone yourself because you don't
have the next gear you need the next
carrot so just keep those things in mind
keep those things in mind about work
ethic but I will tell you out of
everything I told you today in this
video out of everything I told you today
in this video the most important thing I
told you in this video is go back and
study these three words work ethic
morals and then dictate what your
standard of behavior is going to be that
is and is not acceptable to you let's
get my favorite pillow if you haven't
subscribed to the greatest channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs please
subscribe down here and share this
content with other entrepreneurs they do
business with if you run a organization
you have employees and you want them to
improve improve their work ethic share
this video with them as well you got any
questions or thoughts comment on the
bottom I do my best to try to personally
get back to the comments my self art
team some of the questions I get back to
99% of them I get back to some of the
details about hey can I get this can I
get that my staff gets back to the
operator to stuff that they need to but
if I answer your question I'm asked a
question for you because it matters to
me for all the entrepreneurs that follow
this channel so comment on the bottom if
you have any questions and thoughts
subscribe and if you're watching this
video on a complete different website
you can always come back to Patrick
video be calm boom and if you want this
shirt of autodidact which is a
self-taught person go to value Taemin
store calm and get a copy for your get a
shirt for yourself I will tell you more
people ask me about what autodidact
means then I can tell you and this is
coming from an
Didac was a self-taught person cookie
everybody bye-bye